>> Greg: WE ARE THREE DAYS
AWAY FROM THE ANNIVERSARY OF
9/11 AND THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS DON'T FEEL SAFE FROM
THE TERROR THREAT.
THAT'S DOWN FROM 64% A DECADE
AGO, AND MAYBE THIS IS WHY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BOTCHED
AFGHANISTAN'S WITHDRAWAL AND THE
TALIBAN RETURNED TO POWER COULD
TURN THE WAR-TORN COUNTRY BACK
INTO A TERRORIST SAFE HAVEN.
DHS SECRETARY MEI ORCHID SAYS
THAT WHILE THERE IS NO CREDIBLE
THREAT, HE STILL CONCERNED.
>> WE SEEN THE THREAT EVOLVE
FROM THE FOREIGN TERRORIST
SEEKING TO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES TO THE INDIVIDUAL
HERE RADICALIZED TO VIOLENCE BY
A FOREIGN TERRORIST IDEOLOGY TO
NOW WHAT WE CONSIDER THE MOST
SERIOUS TERRORISM RELATED THREAT
ON HER HOMELAND WHICH IS THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENT EXTREMISTS.
SO AM I CONCERNED?
YES.
I'M CONCERNED TODAY, TOMORROW
AND I WAS CONCERNED YESTERDAY.
>> Greg: HE'S NOT TOO
CONCERNED BECAUSE ITS BORDER IS
WIDE OPEN AND PEOPLE ARE JUST
POURING ACROSS.
WHY DO YOU THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE MORE CONCERNED AT
THIS POINT?
>> Dagen: BECAUSE EVERYTHING
AMERICA TOUCHES TURNS TO CHAOS.
JUST SOUNDING LIKE YOU DRANK
HALF A BOTTLE OF BENADRYL
DOESN'T MAKE US FEEL GOOD.
WHEN THE WORLD ASPIRING OUT OF
CONTROL.
IT'S NOT ONLY TO KEEP US SAFE,
THEIR JOBS, IT'S TO MAKE US FEEL
SAFE.
AND YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
AFGHANISTAN CLEARLY BUT IT'S
ALSO THE INABILITY TO STAND UP
TO THE WUHAN VIRUS.
TONY BLINKEN NOT LET OFFICE WILL
LAMBASTE HIM ABOUT AMERICA AND
DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING OR DO
ANYTHING SO WHEN IS BIDEN GOING
TO STAND UP TO CHINA ON THE
WUHAN VIRUS?
YOU CAN CONNECT TO THE TWO
BECAUSE THEY WERE RUNNING BY A
WEAPONS LENS 20 YEARS AGO.
THEY PROBABLY LEARN SOMETHING
FROM THE WHAT, FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE WHO DIED
WORLDWIDE BECAUSE OF A SINGLE
VIRUS THAT SPREAD AROUND, MORE
THAN 650,000 AMERICANS?
SO THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE UTTERLY
FREAKED OUT.
>> Greg: AND IT'S NOT JUST
REPUBLICANS, INDEPENDENTS AND
DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO MUCH MORE
CONCERNED.
>> Dana: INDEPENDENTS ARE
FICKLE VOTERS USUALLY COME UP
THEY PRETTY MUCH DON'T LIKE IT
EITHER POLITICAL PARTY SO THEY
LIKE TO -- AND BASICALLY THEY
DON'T LIKE WASHINGTON.
BUT WHAT YOU WOULD HOPE IS THAT
THEY COULD AT LEAST TRUST
WASHINGTON.
YOU CAN DISLIKE BUT STILL HOPE.
I DO THINK ACTUALLY ON THE
MERITS YOUTH THE UNITED STATES A
SAFER TODAY THAN IT WAS ON
SEPTEMBER 10TH, 2001.
IT'S UNLIVABLE TO THINK ABOUT
NOW BUT AT THE TIME IT WAS
ILLEGAL TO HAVE AN INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
SHARE WITH EACH OTHER.
AND YOU THINK BACK, HOW COULD
THAT POSSIBLY HAVE HAPPENED?
THAT CHANGED WITH THE PATRIOT
ACT.
IT WASN'T PERFECT, BUT THAT
DOESN'T MAKE US SAFER.
IT WAS TRUE THEN AND IT WAS TRUE
NOW.
TERRORISTS ONLY HAVE TO BE RIGHT
ONCE.
THAT COULD BE WITH WEAPONS OF
MASS DESTRUCTION OR NOT.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE RIGHT
ONCE, WE HAVE TO BE RIGHT EVERY
SINGLE TIME WHICH MEANS WE HAVE
TO HAVE A COMMITTED FOCUS.
THE SECOND THING THAT'S TRUE AS
THIS IS A GENERATIONAL WAR ON
IDEOLOGY SO YOU HAVE TO FIGHT IT
FROM VARIOUS DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO STAY ON
OFFENSE AND I WONDER IF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY FEEL LIKE
RIGHT NOW WE ARE ON DEFENSE AND
THAT DOESN'T FEEL GOOD.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S NECESSARILY
TRUE.
CONGRESSMAN MICHAEL WALTZ TODAY
SAID AFGHANISTAN UNDER THE
TALIBAN IS NOW A TERRORIST
SUPERSTATE.
AND JOSH KRAUSHAAR OF THE
NATIONAL JOURNAL, I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND IS CALLED TODAY ABOUT
THE POLITICS OF ALL OF THIS.
YOU COULD SEE A RETURN OF THE
SECURITY MOMS OF 2004 BECAUSE
YES, THE ECONOMY IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BUT IF YOU DO NOT FEEL
SECURE, THAT'S YOUR FIRST
PRIORITY.
>> Greg: SOCCER MOMS, SECURITY
MOUNDS, LOTS OF MOMS, GREG.
>> Greg: SO IF AFGHANISTAN IS
A TERRORIST STATE THEN THAT
MAKES US THE WORLD THE LARGEST
SPONSOR OF TERROR.
WITH LIKE $30 BILLION WORTH OF
WEAPONS.
SO SECRETARY MAYORKAS SO THERE'S
NO CREDIBLE THREAT UNLESS IT'S
WHITE SUPREMACIST AND FACE
PAINT.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, WHY IS IT
THAT WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ENTER
POWER WE INSTINCTIVELY FEEL LESS
SAFE?
IT'S THAT REASON BECAUSE WE'D
MET THE ENEMY AND TO THEM IS
ALWAYS GOING TO BE US.
WE HAD TERROR UNDER BOTH
PARTIES, BUT WE FEEL LIKE THE
DEMS ARE ALWAYS MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR PHOBIC RESPONSE.
AND THEY HAD A TERROR ATTACK.
AND THE PHOBIC RESPONSE, AND
IT'S OFTEN DENIED THE SIGNS OF
ORGANIC TERROR AND CONVERTED
ISLAMIC RADICALS.
MAYBE IF AL QAEDA DECIDES TO
ATTACK IT, WE'VE IDENTIFY AS
WHITE SUPREMACIST WHICH BY THE
WAY AS CULTURAL APPROPRIATION.
THAT WOULD PROBABLY BE THE MOST
OFFENSIVE THING ABOUT IT SO HARD
LEFT PROGRESSIVES.
YOU HAVE TO WARY ABOUT
BIOTERROR, CYBER TERROR AND
ATTACKS ON OUR GRID.
THAT WILL BE THE NEW 9/11 OR
THOSE OF SPECTACLES.
IT'S MORE CONSTRUCTIVE IF YOU
CAN SHUT DOWN COUNTRY.
>> Jessica: LEON PANETTA HAS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS RIGHT
NOW.
WE ARE STARTING TO SEE THAT
CERTAINLY FROM CHINA AND RUSSIA
AND IRAN AND WE WILL SEE HOW THE
MIDDLE EASTERN PLAYERS GET INTO
THIS.
TERMS OF THE DROP, AND AROUND
NINE AND 9/11 THINGS GET ANTSY
OR FOR PEOPLE.
EVERY PAPER YOU OPEN AN CHANNEL
YOU TURN TO, AND THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE HUB OF EXTREMIST
TERROR.
THAT'S COMPOUNDING THINGS FOR
PEOPLE AND GREG HAS MENTIONED A
FEW TIMES THAT THIS IS A STORY
WHERE PEOPLE COULD LARGELY TURN
AWAY FROM OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
EVEN FOREIGN POLICY NUTS ARE
THINKING ABOUT IT AND IT
CERTAINLY MATTERS BUT NOW, THERE
IS NO ESCAPING BASICALLY OUR
WORST NATIONAL NIGHTMARE WHICH
WAS WHAT A NINE.
AND I THINK THAT IS A TOUGH
THING FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND IT'S INFORMING HOW SECRETARY
MAYORKAS IS TALKING ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON, WE SEE THE DOMESTIC
THREAT WHICH HAS BEEN HUGE AND
PREVALENT.
>> I WANT TO THANK
ANDY McCARTHY CUMMINGS TALK TO
ME A LOT ON THE PHONE AND HE IS
DISMAYED THAT WE SEEM TO BE
REPEATING WHAT WE DID 30 YEARS
AGO.
HE SAID THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE JIHADIST ENEMY AND THEY
REFUSE -- TO GREG'S POINT,
CONSERVATIVES GET TREATED AS IF
THEY ARE EVIL BECAUSE WE REFUSE
TO CODDL